لفصل الخوف عن الحقيقة ، جلست
مع اثنين من خبراء الأمراض المعدية في
هونغ كونغ ، فإن فيروس كورونا من صنع الإنسان
إذا نظرت إلى الفيروس نفسه إذا
نظرت إلى شجرة النشوء والتطور وجدنا
أن الفيروس ينبثق
بشكل جيد جدًا بين الأفضل
فيروسات الزاوية وفيروسات الركن الجنوبي ، لذلك
نعتقد أن هذا هو في الواقع
تطورات طبيعية لهذه الرواية من
الفيروسات ، لذلك لم يأت من مختبر في
الصين ،
لم يكن هذا غير محتمل الهندسة الحيوية منذ
بدء تفشي المرض ، كانت هناك موجة
من المعلومات الخاطئة التي حفزت  هذه الرسالة المفتوحة من
قبل العلماء في The Lancet
نظريات المؤامرة لا تفعل شيئًا سوى
إثارة شائعات الخوف والتحيز الذي
يعرض للخطر تعاوننا العالمي
في مكافحة هذا الفيروس ، يمكن
أن يعطيني حيوان أليف الفيروس لأننا نعلم أن
حيوانًا أليفًا هنا في هونغ كونغ قد ثبتت
إصابته بالفيروس.  من غير المحتمل جدًا أن يكون فيروس كورونا الجديد
الذي تم إطلاقه على الحيوان الأليف في الحجر الصحي
، ومن المرجح أن يكون
الكلب
ملوثًا بيئيًا على الرغم من أنه كان كذلك
ملوثًا لن تحصل على
حمولة فيروسية عالية جدًا ومن غير المحتمل جدًا
أن تنتقل بالفعل من
الحيوانات الأليفة إليك ، فهذا أمر غير محتمل للغاية الآن ،
هذا كبير الحجم الذي يرتدي قناعًا لن
يحميني من الفيروس لأنه
كان لديك الجراح الأمريكي  بشكل عام ، إخبار
الأشخاص أنك لست بحاجة إلى شراء قناع ،
إنه ليس فعالاً ، إذا نظرت إلى
البيانات في هونج كونج ، ربما يكون ارتداء الأقنعة هو
أهم شيء فيما
يتعلق بمكافحة العدوى.
فيروسات الزوايا ،
فهي تقلل الإنفلونزا في الواقع ، هذا هو
الآن موسم الأنفلونزا ولم
نر أي تأثير للحالات ،
وذلك لأن الكتلة تحمي في الواقع ليس
فقط من اللوريس المتكرر ولكن أيضًا
من فيروسات الإنفلونزا أيضًا
[موسيقى
]  يعد فيروس كورونا أقل فتكًا من
الأنفلونزا ، فكيف يقارنون إذا نظرت
إلى حالات Dowson التي أبلغ عنها
الأستاذ جون وشين في الطب الباطني الجديد
، فإن معدل الوفيات في الأساس
يبلغ حوالي 1  .4 في المائة أو من المحتمل
أن تنخفض هي المقام وتزداد حجمها ،
لذا فهي لا تزال تقف عند
حوالي 1 في المائة لأن الأنفلونزا
بنسبة واحد في المائة أو حتى أقل اعتمادًا على
المواسم التي تعيش فيها ، لذا فهي لا تزال
أكثر فتكًا بعشر مرات مقارنة
بفيروس الأنفلونزا  سيختفي في أبريل / نيسان ، لقد
سمعنا أنه من العديد من الناس ، نعم ،
أعتقد أنه من قبيل
التكهن ، أرى الناس يقولون ذلك جزئيًا
لأن السارس قد اختفى في
أبريل / مايو ولكن عندما يكون الجو دافئًا هنا
سيكون باردًا في مكان آخر  لدينا
نصف كرة جنوبي أيضًا في الصلصة يتأثر فقط
في عدد قليل من البلدان ولكن هذه
المرة حقًا مقياس للوباء ،
لذا يمكن أن يعود بشكل أساسي خاصةً
نصف الكرة الأرضية ثم تعرف البديل
مع نصف الكرة الشمالي